a Texas man who lost his wife in the El
Paso shooting spree earlier this month
is getting heartfelt support as he
prepares to lay her to rest today
Margy record had very few relatives so
her husband invited anyone to attend her
funeral hundreds of strangers including
people from as far away as Japan helped
bid farewell Mireya Villarreal reports
most of the people waiting outside in
the sweltering El Paso heat never met 63
year old Margie record or her husband
Antonio Bosco we came to the service
because we wanted to show our support
record was gunned down two weeks ago
while shopping inside the Cielo Vista
Wal Mart it was the deadliest act of
violence this city has ever seen since
then Antonio's visited the memorial site
every day a post from the funeral home
handling records services give a bit
more insight into the couple's life in
this border town mr. Antonio Bosco was
married for 22 years to his wife Margie
record he had no other family he
welcomes anyone to attend his wife's
services that one post went viral
prompting people from all over the world
to send flowers and gifts the church
could only hold 500 people but that
didn't seem to bother mourners outside
waiting for their chance to say goodbye
I would be feeling the same as he is now
without a family
no insight so we are his family
this memorial was meant to honor one of
the 22 people that lost their lives on
August 3rd but it also gave the
community another chance to heal we are
here for him this was a way to show not
just one man but the entire world that
kindness and humanity are far more
powerful than hate we told him that
apostle left him and this is his home
and he has family here he's not alone
Antonio Bosco may have thought he didn't
have any relatives left here in El Paso
but Friday night's service showed he had
a family of thousands for CBS this
morning Saturday media vol El Paso it
never ceases to amaze me the beauty and
humanity you see in people when they
come together after a tragedy like that
just what we might have all watched that
yeah gives you hope didn't it